une chemise fabriqué en france un
produit devenu rare ces dernières années
à chalon les ateliers gauthier sont
l'une des quatre dernières manufactures
à préserver encore ce savoir-faire
défendre le made in france c'est le
moteur de michel de saint jean depuis
plus d'une dizaine d'années
pas toujours facile quand on ne trouve
pas sa principale matière première dans
l'hexagone
85% des tissus viennent des peignes et
il ya quelqu'un qui suit japonais
maintenant de plus en plus qui sont
qualitativement également supérieure
pour le sens pour s'enfoncer il faut
donc attendre même si de nouvelles
pistes apparaissent
j'ai enfin réussi à obtenir 1 1 des
tissus de qualité avec un tisseur
lyonnais qui s'appelle vernet clay et
qui lui s'est spécialisée davantage sur
les tissus techniques avec du polyester
recyclé des éléments comme ça vingt-cinq
salariés travaillent dans l'entreprise
créée en 1947 au plus fort de l'activité
ils étaient une centaine une époque
avant la crise de l'industrie textile et
la mécanisation
mais la maison a résisté et su allier la
modernisation des outils avec la
préservation des gestes et du savoir
faire derrière chaque machine il y à une
main et c'est très important justement
on pense souvent quoi on peut
automatiser à outrance mais ces belles
cartes donc la machine vient compléter
le travail manuel
l'entreprise développe sa marque mais
travaille aussi pour des maisons de luxe
et sur mesure en moyenne une centaine de
pièces sortent chaque jour des ateliers
une production loin des volumes
industriels disait le hooligan qu'il
existait un choix qui se paye il faut
compter au moins 150 euros pour l'une de
ses chemises aujourd'hui de la chemise
en trouver en chine au bangladesh
la production de masse donc il y à des
marchés qui corresponde à ce besoin
tant mieux mais c'est pas notre on n'a
aucune chance de lutter contre cela donc
nous notre positionnement c'est
justement de travailler les matières les
finitions le soin apporté un produit
pour que le consommateur il en est entre
guillemets pour son argent
ce week end les ateliers gauthier
présenteront leurs chemises au salon du
made in france à paris on peut emmener
des motifs typiquement hiver comme celle
là où celle ci qui est original avec les
boutons pression une vitrine
incontournable pour un secteur encore
fragile
nous sommes un des derniers fabricants
de chemise et un des derniers fabricants
avoir une marque propre et pour moi
personnellement il est très important
que dans notre pays on puisse encore
porter une chemise fabriqués en france
conçu en france et voilà que le
consommateur est cette liberté là à
dijon cette boutique spécialisée dans
les produits français distribuer les
chemises gauthier le prix y est parfois
un frein pour certains clients mais il
ya bien une demande pour ses vêtements
dont on connaît l'origine ceux qui
franchissent la porte en ayant déjà
cette idée de vouloir consommer local ou
au moins un français ont déjà passé ce
cap du prix et sam à quoi s'attendre et
surtout ils consomment ils ont une
consommation plus raisonnée c'est à dire
qu'ils vont consommer moins mais mieux
et donc vont préférer acheter un peu
plus cher dans l'intemporel mais qui
durera dans le temps au salon de paris
les chemises chalonnaise côtoieront des
parapluies d'autun ou des chaussettes de
montceau-les-mines tous dérivés d'un
héritage textile bien ancrée en
bourgogne et qui ne demandent qu'à
participer au renouveau du made in
france